all right good
people of the internet i am dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for today
5 12 20 21 as always
subscribe to our youtube channel tap
that notification bell
see what happens you never know there is
a ton
to get to today so i'm gonna try to
cover as much
as possible i want to preface everything
that i'm going to do
today by saying that i do not consider
myself a journalist
now we don't have many journalists these
days we've got
journalists meaning we've got activists
that work at cnn and the new york times
and that you know basically pretend
these are people who pretend
they larp live action role play they
larp as journalists but they're usually
democrat or lefty
or woke activists more than anything
else and one of the things that i've
been talking about on this show now for
months and months is that we've been
in a reality war that is what so much of
the
the tension is about we don't know what
our neighbors believe we don't know what
our families member believe members
believe
and depending on what the algorithms are
feeding you who you're following
what you're reading you know what social
circles you're in all of those things
you could basically live in a completely
alternate reality
as someone else and that tension
cannot last for that long it just can't
last for that long
and we could look back and go oh well
you know say in the 1970s when we had
three network news channels abc nbc cbs
and walter cronkite
and it was before cable news like we
could all sort of agree on basic facts
but
we didn't get that many facts right we
didn't get a broad swath of information
because they were all on at 6 30.
you kind of saw the same thing on each
channel you know maybe you basically
watched one because you like peter
jennings
more than you like dan rather more than
you like tom brokaw or something like
that
but there was a limited amount of
information and it's better that we have
more information
of course i'm a more information guy i
want there to be more information out
there
but we really need to figure out a way
to get to something truthful and i think
at this point and i'll get to a bunch of
this
related to the stories today the reality
war
that i've been talking about has
basically morphed into a war
on truth there is an absolute war on
truth and i think we are running out of
people
that are willing to stand up for truth
and before i get to the stories i just
want to hearken back to a video i showed
last week
when jordan peterson was on the tucker
carlson
show on fox nation not his fox news show
and
they were talking about truth and jordan
said that at one point
in his life when he was around 25 years
old he decided to start telling the
truth
for truth's sake not that telling the
truth will automatically mean
a good conclusion will come you could
tell the truth in some pretty brutal
things to use a jordan peterson
adjective some pretty brutal things
could happen to you
but if you believe that the truth is
inherently good
and right then no matter what happens if
you tell the truth it will be better
than all the possible
alternatives may not be the easiest walk
down the road but it will
be better than all the others and then
jordan went on to say that that in and
of itself
is the ultimate expression of faith that
i will tell the truth for truth's sake
damned be the consequences that that
actually is an expression of faith that
makes a lot of sense to me
that actually connects the mind and the
heart to me and and the spirit to me in
a way that i think is really
powerful and i'm really trying to do it
and i'm going to just clean up some
some of the mess that's out there right
now because the truth is under assault
real quick i was on twitter this morning
and and twitter you
ignorant [ __ ] nobody should be on
twitter it's a horrible horrible place
uh but i tweeted out a video yesterday
uh of a bunch of israelis sitting in an
israeli town and a bomb just going off
there and you see the fireball and
people running and all of that stuff
and in effect well let's put up the
first tweet that i put out there and
then we'll get to the stories
i wrote israel can we yeah let's get up
there i said israel is the only place
where muslims jews and christians live
peacefully and equally under the law
that's what hamas and the ilhan omar
crowd are taking direct aim at now
obviously i'm talking
about the uh the middle east there of
course right we're doing it pretty well
in america now i know that the workstars
and the marxists
and the communists don't like america
either and they're not happy with our
coexistence but obviously i'm talking
about israel and then this morning
and i hate to get into these little
twitter fracases but then marianne
williamson the former democratic
candidate
for president who i had on the show she
tweeted at me she said just not true
dave it's just not true now she did what
lefties tend to do with arguments she
didn't make an argument she didn't make
a statement
or give me anything i could rebut there
she just said that what i said
is untrue now it is a hundred percent
fact that that is true you can go
to jerusalem even right now and there
are women
muslim women in burkas on buses with
orthodox jewish men it doesn't mean that
it's perfect
but the 20 of israeli arabs who live in
israel have more voting rights and more
equality than any arab in any other
country
fact this is just a fact i know it's an
uncomfortable fact for the haters but
it's just
a fact but she did what they always do
which is instead of
actually making a statement that i could
refute just says this blanket thing in
essence calling me a liar
so i wrote and i'm sorry that i'm giving
you guys this in a certain respect
because these twitter things
are sort of nonsensical but i think this
illustrates a broader point
so and especially because the woman ran
for president for god sakes
i said how about say a statement i can
actually refute
where in the middle east is there any
coexistence remotely like israel
also remember when you told me how
insane hatred from the left is
and that you understand why i'm why i'm
more libertarian strange that you said
that when the cameras were off okay so
then i
i did escalate the situation there so
just to be clear
again there's no place with that has the
coexistence like israel and in many ways
that's
that's actually what's under attack
right now because the marxists and the
communists the votes they don't want
coexistence right they're actually the
racist okay i think you guys get all
that
the reason i went in on marianne here uh
is because she not only did she do the
usual lefty attack which is you're not
saying anything you're just implying
that i'm a liar
but when i ended my interview with her
and many of you saw that interview i
treated her with 100
respect the same exact way i've treated
every single one of my guests i suspect
anyone watching this
even my haters that are watching this uh
that you've never seen me treat any
guests differently i treat all my guests
the same
as a matter of fact it became so obvious
in the middle of the interview with
with marianne williamson that we so look
at the world differently meaning she's a
collectivist
she believes in collective guilt she
believes white people should be
collectively guilty
for the for the sins or even the not
sins of their ancestors no one in my
family owned slaves
um she's a collectivist and i'm an
individualist i believe you should be
judged
on your actions and your thoughts and
your words but i wanted to treat her
fairly so i actually stopped in the
middle of the interview you guys can
check it out and i said hey i just want
to stop for a second
and just say that we have a fundamental
impasse here in terms of our philosophy
of life but but let's go ahead and
and keep talking which we did now the
reason that i even brought up this other
thing
is because after the interview the
second the cameras went off
she started going all in on the hate she
gets from the left and how bananas the
left has gone
and that they they're not liberal
anymore and she understands why
i'm more libertarian and the rest of it
it was like well lady why didn't you say
any of that
when you were on camera so i felt sort
of like exposing marianne williamson
because that's exactly
what she did that when she was on air
she says one thing and when she's off
air she says another thing by the way
just in case you think i'm making that
up she also got caught on a live
mic moment i think on what what show is
that on um
there was a live mic moment i think it
maybe was on an oan show
or a newsmax show where she said the
exact same thing meaning she thought she
was off air
and the second she gets off air she's
talking about how evil the left is and
she understands why the right calls them
godless and everything else
so i'm not making this up i assure you
in any event i don't want to get lost in
twitter drama
but i decided you know marianne and i
think you're watching marianne because i
i
i'm doing this show in honor of you and
i tweeted you the link and everything
um i decided i know you love crystals i
don't have any crystals here
but i do have a rock i went out uh right
before
the show i just went out into the
backyard oh
uh the show that she was on where she
got caught on the hot mic we're
basically saying the exact same thing
i'm telling you she said to me
on on uh hot mic was the eric bowling
show and you can find that clip it went
viral
uh but i don't have any crystals and i
know you love crystals i do have a rock
and i found this rock in the backyard
it's a very nice actually
gray is sort of polished soft you know
very lovely rock here
and i wrote marianne stinks on it and i
signed it dave rubin
and i'm going to give this rock away so
someone
in the reuben report community if you go
to reubenreport.locals.com
just post why you'd like this rock
that's all just post
why you'd like the marianne williamson
rock again i apologize for not having a
power crystal or whatever those things
are
i've got a rock and i want someone to
have
that rock have a great day marianne
all right guys before i get to
everything else i want to talk to you
about bonner private wine
you know if you're a health conscious
red wine lover like me here's how to
make your next drink 10 times healthier
down in argentina they make this really
dark red wine from malbec grapes grown
at 9000 feet
they've lab tested these wines and found
that they contain up to 10 times the
levels of a longevity and heart
health nutrient called resveratrol
resveratrol's powerful stuff
it pops up again and again in studies on
longevity heart health and brain health
these wines also have 90 percent less
sugar fewer chemicals fewer additives
plus if you love steak and bbq like i do
red wine
has been shown to actually make red meat
healthier
but the best thing about these wines is
that they taste great with notes of
blackberry leather cherry and smoke
today the guys at freethinkerwine.com
are giving you 50
off their best malbecs and if you'll
order right now you'll also get 50
off shipping wine makes a great gift
even if it's just for yourself
trust me i know just visit
freethinkerwine.com today that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay and i just again
if you want this
rock i love i was thinking about this
the whole time i'm reading that thing
it's like man people are gonna want this
rock marianne people want this rock
marianne stinks signed by dave rubin
right from my backyard people
picked it up myself you can get that
rock just tell me why you want it at
rugenreport.locals.com okay so there's
obviously a ton going on in the middle
east
and i would preface this all by saying
you know we had four years of that
orange guy remember orange guy
and there were five uh peace deals
struck in the middle east there was
virtually no violence uh to speak of
related to the israelis and the
palestinians
the embassy moved we moved the american
embassy from tel aviv to the capital of
israel which is jerusalem
the media went bananas the blue and
non-media oh there's going to be
violence and mass death and everything
else no there was nothing and then
actually other countries started doing
the same
and things were actually shifting in a
new way by looking at the middle east in
a new way things were getting more
peaceful right and
you know i know him i know i'm a dreamer
but i always thought middle east peace
was something that we all kind of
we all kind of wanted well it seems to
be crumbling at a
rapid pace right now and this is in
large part to the biden administration
that is flat out just going back to the
obama policies
excuse me
a lot of talking people uh so basically
the bible administration is going back
to all of the sort of failed stuff
with the obama administration um
so let me just catch you up on a little
bit of what's gone on over the last
little bit the this is from stan with us
in the past 48 hours over 500 rockets
were fired from gaza into israel and
then of course israel
is responding with targeted bombings of
gaza
and unfortunately the hamas operatives
they use
schools and hospitals and places where
there are women and children to shoot
the rockets from
thus israel has to respond and people
are going to get killed it's just how it
is
we've got this absolutely incredible
video i'm sure many of you have seen
this already
it's just extraordinary from a guy by
the name of joe truesman
and this is watching israel's iron dome
take out rockets so what you're going to
be seeing here
are rockets are flying in from gaza and
the iron dome is shooting these rockets
out of the sky i mean it's truly a
modern miracle take a look
okay so hundreds of those rockets are
flying all over the country and for
every one of those rockets that are
indiscriminately fired they could land
in a kindergarten they could land at a
library an old age home
doesn't matter that's part of what they
want the chaos to do so the iron dome is
actually pretty incredible
they actually let some of the rockets go
so if they see the rocket's going to hit
an open field or something like that
they don't waste the missile shooting it
down
but you can see it's blowing up all
sorts of rockets over there
but of course this is causing all sorts
of chaos all
over the world because there seems to be
some sort of theory related to no jews
no news
and uh people are going bananas and
rashida talib who's
one of the main members of the squad and
i've been trying to tell people for a
long time that the democratic party
of yesterday is completely gone it has
been rotted out it is a it is awoke i
would argue
at this point basically socialist party
um well there was a
free palestine rally and rashida talib
showed up
and you really listen to her listen to
her language
and listen to the specifics of what
she's saying
what they do understand is that people
died solely because
of who they are because they were
palestinian
because they were of a certain faith
whatever it is they were completely
alienated killed and the ethnic
cleansing continues now
and so i tell all of you will not
you will not whitewash you will not take
away my family's
ancestors history thousands and
thousands thousands and thousands
continue to be displaced and
pushed out of their homes in their land
enough
and so many folks are going to continue
to try to gaslight us target us bully us
but we won't we will not be pushed down
because we all deserve to live
freely and with human dignity all right
so
she's a liar on many fronts so first off
ethnic cleansing she's claiming that
there's ethnic cleansing and we hear
this all the time that there's a
genocide of gaza
actually let's jump ahead for a second
let's let's show the map uh i'm sorry so
let's show the not the map
let's show the the population growth in
gaza the next one
yeah so this is the population growth in
gaza we will post the link to it down
below
you can find this all over the place but
the population growth in gaza
is actually exploding it's actually
exploding so if this is a genocide
or ethnic cleansing it's the worst one
imaginable now in a real genocide a real
ethnic cleansing
say the holocaust for example when six
million jews were exterminated in europe
the population drops but this way the
population
is going up so she is just saying that
something that is
completely untrue now let's jump back to
the first map of the let's show the map
of the middle east okay so
one of the things that i think is a
problem related to talking about this
part of the world is nobody has a
freaking clue
what the size and geographic situation
of any of this stuff is so
israel is an absolutely tiny country in
a pretty rough neighborhood there's
there's one tiny little jewish state
there's many arab states there right
okay that's just fine it's a tiny little
state there
basically the size of new jersey just to
give you some context so can we pull up
the the map of the united states uh do
we have that map of the united states
yeah so there you're seeing
the map of the united states and israel
is basically the size of new jersey in a
very tiny
little area now let's show the close-up
of israel
let me pull that up for just a sec yeah
okay so here's a close-up of israel what
you're seeing right there
and what you're seeing is uh gaza is the
sort of bottom by the water
with that border of egypt and you hear
all these people saying israel is
trapping them they're trapping them
in gaza well there is a border with the
with
egypt there is a border with egypt and
by the way nobody wants to talk about
this but egypt used to control
gaza until 1967 and then they tried to
invade israel
and lost a war right there was no
palestine there's no palestine
nation if when people tell you there was
a palestine who was the prime minister
who was the president it didn't exist
and i'll get into the history
in just a second i know this is sort of
all exhausting to talk about because
it's like why should anyone
care about any of this but i'm trying to
just clean up some of the things that
are so
untrue so let's let's just put the that
close-up map up again
so when you see a map like this and you
so you're first seeing how tiny israel
is with a bunch of much bigger states
that aren't that thrilled
that that the jews carved out this tiny
little place in the middle east that has
no oil
also a bunch of them have some oil well
if israel was doing all these horrible
things to the gazans by the way
if there was ethnic cleansing in gaza
they took all the jews out you may
remember that about 20 years ago they
took every single jew out
they left greenhouses they left temples
they left structures for
the palestinians to rebuild things and
they burned them all down but
israel actually did ethnic cleansing of
jews they took every jew out of gaza so
hitler would love gaza
it's completely jude and ryan right
there's no no jews in gaza maybe there's
probably one very confused jew who got
left something like that
um but the border sorry put it up one
more time the border there as you can
see there's a border with egypt so you
would think
that their brothers their brothers in
egypt if israel was slaughtering
the gazans mercilessly you would think
they would let them through the border
but no
actually in 2014 egypt bombed the hell
out of the border blowing up tons of
houses blowing up tunnels that people
were making their way
into egypt through again you can google
this don't trust me
don't take my word for it so they are
partaking
in the blockade they are take partaking
in the borders because egypt wants to
have its borders by the way the part one
more time on that map please
uh by the way the part of egypt that
you're seeing there when you see egypt
the word egypt
that's actually straddling egypt proper
and that whole huge area right below
israel there
that's sinai israel actually won that
entire piece of land
which is bigger than israel itself they
won
that piece of land after a war and what
did they do
they gave it back in honor of a piece of
paper saying let's have peace with egypt
which is basically
what they've had even if it is a a cold
piece and then let's just throw up one
other one other map let's throw up the
the four pictures there
uh from the ottoman empire and the
united nations okay so what you're
seeing here so
there's also a lot of confusion so when
i say that that palestine never existed
it never existed as a nation meaning
that there were arabs and jews who owe
and christians by the way and and
druze and all sorts of other people who
lived in an area that at times was known
as palestine by the way there were parts
of it the west bank we now know call it
the west bank
for centuries it was known as judea and
samaria right like that's
jews lived in judea that jesus guy
lived in bethlehem that's in the west
bank jesus jew he was a jew
that story about hanukkah when the jews
are defending the judean hills the
maccabees are defending the judean hills
against
the greeks that's in the west bank judea
so
rashida talib it's like you don't even
want any jews to live there now
i'm not even making an argument actually
over who is there first and what but the
point is we should know some
basic truth so what we're showing you
right now is that
pretty much before world war one okay
for many many years for hundreds of
years in essence the place known as
palestine which was not a nation it was
just this area that there was pretty
much nothing there
also by the way it was sort of a swamp
in a desert
it was controlled by the ottoman empire
then at the end of world war one
the ottoman empire collapsed and the
british took over so then there was
something called the british mandate of
palestine it was part
of england and they uh basically
controlled the entire area again there
was no
nation of palestine there was no arab or
muslim nation known
as palestine and jews live there and
arabs live there and christians live
there
and you can find new york times articles
you can find new york times articles
from
that time where the arab countries are
boycotting palestine and the reason
they're boycotting palestine
is because palestine is where the jews
were there was something called the
palestine
post which is now the jerusalem post
because it was the jews
having the newspaper and the soccer team
the official soccer team
was the palestinian soccer team it was a
bunch of jews okay so then what happened
in 1947 the british were like okay we've
got to get out of here because the
middle east is a freaking mess
so they offered the 1947 partition plan
and they said
basically we're going to split these
things up we're going to have an arab
state
and a jewish state there was no
palestinian state because there was no
people known as palestinians they were
arabs that lived in that area that's
just fine
it's just true the israelis the to be
israelis the jews said yes we'll take
the split
and the arabs said no and then what
happened israel then went ahead and said
okay then we're a nation
and all the arab countries launched a
war and then what you're getting
so now we're looking at the third one
here the the rejection
then you have what israel is right now
in 1967 and this is the fourth image
there and i'm trying to run through a
whole bunch of this real quick for you
guys this is like a crazy thing
to do in 1967 there was another war
launched by all the arab countries
and uh and in essence there was an
occupation
or israel basically took back the west
bank
from jordan that's what you're seeing on
the right over there and they took the
gaza
from egypt so from 1948 from the
beginning of israel
to 1967 they won a war in 48 and then
one war in 67
that in essence is where gaza and the
west bank came from so they were never a
continuous thing they were never a
nation
or anything like that the last two
images that you're seeing in essence the
first time the palestinians ever got any
sort of self-determination when they
allowed the palestinian authority to
come in and say okay you can govern over
your own people
in the west bank is the oslo accords
which was 1994 right
and most people think it was probably a
mistake at this point but that's when
they got some level of autonomy so
ironically it was israel who gave them
some level of autonomy anyway i know
this was a little bit
a little bit messy and i'm trying to do
a lot of stuff at once and it's it's a
very
um it's so complex
um but nothing that i said here was
unfactual
nothing that i said here was unfactual i
know that i'll probably get marianne
williamson calling me a liar
or something like that but the point is
and all of this being said all this
being said
you still have two peoples who are not
thrilled with each other and you got to
figure out how to make
something work but if you think that
indiscriminately firing rockets into a
country
uh is going to get that to happen well
then that doesn't make any sense i mean
every country
i would say this about every single
country on earth every single country
has the duty
it is the sh actually the number one
responsibility to defend its citizens
that's what it is so if hamas thinks
that they're defending their citizens by
doing this
it doesn't seem like that's really
working right and israel has to defend
their citizens it's as simple as that
hopefully i don't have to do these
history lessons that often but i hope
that gave you a little bit of context
we'll post some of the links down below
so that you'll be able
to get some real information yourself
but everything that i just said there is
true hopefully it wasn't
too messy i think i made some sense of
it
so there you go all right let's move on
uh rand paul
got into a big fracas with dr fauci
the other day uh it's actually quite
amazing so we've got a couple quotes
here from mediaite and of course this is
all about what's going on with kovid
dr anthony fauci and senator rand paul
engage in an epic battle over the
origins
of the deadly kovit 19 contagion and
here's the key part
so there are two competing theories of
its origins one
is that it emanated from wet markets in
wuhan china that sold
civets which had contracted sars coveted
two
from wild bats the other theory is that
the deadly pathogen came from a world
famous
virology lab lab based in wuhan either
accidentally or via some more
conspiratorial means now let's show you
some video of rand paul and dr fauci
the nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research
in the woohon institute do they find our
doctor
we do not fund do you find dr barracks
gain of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina i don't think it's concerning a
bat virus spike protein that he got from
the wuhan institute into the sars virus
his gain of function
that is not a minority because at least
200 scientists have signed a statement
from the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function the
nih and niaid
categorically has not funded gain of
function research
to be conducted in the wuhan institute
of iran you support it in the u.s we
have 11 labs doing it and you have
allowed it here we have a committee to
do it but the committee is granted
every exemption you're you're fooling
with mother nature here you're allowing
super viruses to be created
with a 15 mortality it's very dangerous
i think it was a huge mistake to share
this with china
and it's a huge mistake to allow this to
continue in the united states
and we should be very careful to
investigate where this virus came from
i fully agree that you should
investigate where the virus
came from okay so
what you're hearing there is some debate
as to whether the
where the virus came from it seems to me
now i don't have all the information on
this
it seems to me that rand paul is trying
to figure out exactly
what's going on here and who funded it
and where it came from
but it sort of feels like this is
something we're not supposed to talk
about right like are they going to show
this on cnn are they going to talk about
this
on the new york times like we should
know what happened here
did this come this thing this virus that
in essence has shut down the world
for a year and a half that's still has
countries in various states of lockdown
i mean you all know what's happening up
in canada
you know what's happening in all sorts
of different states here in the united
states
should we actually do the research to
find out who was funding the lab
in wuhan did it come from the wet
markets
are there corporate interests that have
any connections to any of these things
that maybe fauci's involved in or any of
this stuff like
should we be allowed to talk about it
that that's all i'm asking here i
actually don't have a
i don't have a definitive statement on
what i actually think happened here
i happen to think that rand paul is a
pretty decent guy
i happen to think that he's someone
that's thorough that actually is always
watching
out for the ever encroaching power of
the government and then of course you
have
fauci who's sort of doing the reverse he
really likes seemingly
likes to have the power to keep us in
lockdowns and wearing 87 masks and not
visiting family members and everything
else so my only takeaway from that is we
should at least be talking about this
stuff
anyway we're actually going to drop our
third story which is about the gas
shortages because i went a little bit
long today because obviously that first
story was
a lot to unpack and i have no doubt that
it will be clipped and my haters will be
out and about but i believe that telling
the truth is important i will keep
talking about this stuff i will try to
analyze it and bring it to you in the in
the clearest way that i know how
and again i do not consider myself a
journalist we live in a time
where journalism has been decimated by
journalists
and then it leaves a couple people i
suppose to try to make some
sense of the world and that is really
just how it is and it's a it's a very
strange thing
uh part three of my interview with
senator josh hawley
uh is up right now it's all about big
tech and what we can do what we should
do what maybe we should have done that
we didn't do
and all that good stuff the full episode
of course is up already early and
ad-free at reubenreport.locals.com and
speaking
of that if you want this rock
marianne sucks because she didn't make
an argument to me and then when the
cameras went off
she said something completely different
than she did for the hour we were on
camera if you want that just tell me why
at reubenreport.locals.com and our
friday panel
is with two of my favorite guests and
good friends uh douglas murray
and peter bogosian they are doing a
documentary with filmmaker
travis brown and it's all about colleges
and locism and
all the stuff the stuff that we talk
about all the time okay guys this
this felt like some heavy lifting today
uh i think i did it in a pretty
in a pretty functional way with a lot of
a lot of papers in front of me but
mostly just the stuff
that that i know to be true and we
sourced all of this stuff and i would
welcome you to look
at those maps look at the maps related
to the sizes here
look at the maps understand that the
ottoman empire existed and that
the british empire existed and that
there were peace deals that were turned
down i think
i think in total the palestinians have
rejected six peace deals six offers of
would you like a state
we will give you a state and six times
they said no bill clinton i mean i have
no great love
for bill clinton but bill clinton in his
book talks about how
when they were doing the trying to have
their peace deals with yasser arafat and
ahud barak
that basically barack made all the
concessions and arafat basically was
like look if i take this deal my own
people are going to kill me so we're not
going to take it and then he never
showed up to the subsequent meeting
i think i'm getting that basically right
um so it's just
it's just messy and i'll try to continue
to have conversations about this stuff
that that hopefully will clean things up
instead of adding more fuel to the fire
but you know
i'm just human too so anyway have a
great day everybody oh i'm heading off
to
uh dallas i'm going to dallas sometimes
i don't even know where i'm going
i'm going to dallas i'm going to be
doing some documentary stuff down there
and then a whole bunch of stuff with the
blaze guys
on friday so we are pre-taping the
friday show that i just mentioned
um so maybe i'll do a meet-up in dallas
let's see what we can
figure out uh but if you want to find
out about it report.locals.com all right
have a great day everybody don't go
crazy it's all gonna be okay
we've been through this before life's
weird but it finds a way okay
that's it